it is interesting that the age joke in
21 jump street all these years later is
still relevant in terms of casting the
fact that you look like a 40 year old
man i find that funny
[Music]
so dear evan hansen is a movie it's a
film adaptation that's also a musical
that's based off of the the production
the play the musical it's funny because
i've seen a lot of conversations out
there people like oh this is like my
favorite musical i can't wait to see the
movie i hope the movie's as good as the
musical the musical itself is quite
loved after watching the movie i mean i
can't well i can kind of see why but i
can't it doesn't really sell you on it
the premise of the movie is there's this
dude evan hansen he's a very socially
awkward high school student has a lot of
anxiety he has a run-in with this other
student who ends up killing himself and
then people get the idea that evan
hansen and this now deceased student
they were best friends and so he kind of
creates a lie that leads to another lie
it leads to another lie that gives
people hope he's doing the wrong things
for the right reasons the allegory of
the story is that the truth will always
come out and lies are not worth it also
that happiness is built on the brick and
mortar of absolute [ __ ] if you want
happiness just embed yourself in lies
sure until it falls apart but this movie
does have some interesting allegory and
themes more in concept and execution
conceptually speaking you look at the
themes in this movie you're like yeah
that's there are a lot of themes that
are gonna hit a lot of people very
differently you can throw a bunch of
people into one auditorium they'll all
walk out with a different takeaway i
always find that interesting in a movie
i do appreciate that it shows that
people deal with grief differently and
if you're dealing with grief you will
latch onto a lie even when evidence is
totally flying in the face of it you're
like no no i need this human connection
how you can be connected to a story even
when the story is not true then there's
a side of how the internet deals with
this information you know it did have
some interesting themes but again very
much in concept it stars ben platt as
evan hansen who i guess played this
character in the play in the onstage
production i can completely see why the
dude can belt out the notes he's really
good at singing as a great voice and
also he's really good in the role as the
character credit where credits do a lot
of the cast they did a really good job
in the movie but you can't help when
looking at the dude you're like you are
clearly not a high school student here
here you go here's some information in
2012 in pitch perfect i believe he
played a college student now all these
years later nine years later he's
playing a high school student which you
can get away with on broadway or musical
production a play you know the audience
is far enough away to where you can't
really see that but when you're dealing
with a movie that has close-ups it
doesn't matter the makeup that they're
trying to do
you can just tell i just couldn't help
but watching the movie i'm looking at
the dude he looks like the quirky cool
uncle who's trying to dress much younger
than he is but he's now breached into
high school so it's weird but all that
aside although the movie had some fun
musical numbers some fun edits in there
but my biggest thing about this movie is
the pacing i walked out of this movie i
literally said to myself i got in my car
and i was like
that was the longest [ __ ] movie i've
ever seen in my life i mean these are
ten commandments which is i don't know
logistically numerically it's ten
commandments but dude
you feel it it just drags on enough to
where i was when the end credits hit i
was like i'm out i got things to do
life's too short to sit here for one
minute longer pacing man there's a point
where it's like oh the movie's gonna end
it's only been an hour this is why i
wear watches to movie theaters so i can
chronicle how boring it's getting and
when and that pacing to me was the
detriment of the entire thing i make
jokes about the fact that the lead looks
30. but these are just jokes you know
those are things that you notice but if
the movie really stuck the landing you
wouldn't give a [ __ ] which i suppose is
a clever way of saying yeah watch the
musical apparently it's better says the
masses i've seen a lot of people hate
the movie it's not like i hate it i'm
just indifferent watch the movie i was
like okay it had some really shallow
development among some of the friends in
the movie i was buying the relationship
between the lead and this girl who's
running this charity in the name of the
student who died much more than i was
buying the relationship between him and
his actual love interest in the movie i
get it you can have friends that aren't
love interest but i was like these two
just
seem to click more it's just one of
those movies that you walk out of you're
like oh i saw that it happened
it's filler it's a movie i'm not really
gonna remember in t minus one day yep
already forgot if nothing else if the
play if the musical is that much better
hopefully it sparks interest for people
to see that all right so dear evan
hansen have you seen it
have you i don't know maybe youtube ads
or where all the marketing is but when i
was at the theater and i was like yeah
that high school musical movie that's
not actually high school musical but is
a musical that i haven't heard of before
today and she was like oh yeah dear evan
hansen there you go one ticket she knew
what i was talking about i feel like
that speaks volumes i'm actually curious
or what's a movie that's also a play
that you actually like either or it's
kind of a convoluted question was the
best i got today but whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you